yeah I think it's a learning curve for
him too because I feel like he's kind of
always done [__] where it's like just
him and who is recording and editing and
like to like bringing all these
personalities and like you know he's
never really signed people so I think
that like there's that narrative where
he was like well in hindsight maybe I
should have signed him and it's like and
that I don't know if y'all saw me on the
show oh I was watching and I was like
well if you were enter you know
encourage them to to go and do their own
thing
like wouldn't that be like with the idea
that they might do very well and that's
and that was where I was that's another
reason why I'm looking at it a little
differently too because it's like if you
pushing us to do these things
and we reach in certain Heights and to
me it made you look good right like I'm
a boss that put on these other bosses
and put them in position not like oh we
on competition for each other and I feel
that's when the comments and uh these
outside narratives keep coming out
instead of really looking at who the
people are right you know what I'm
saying because we can get into it I can
get into him but I can talk to him I
don't have to be like hey bro [__] or
tell somebody something bad about him
and keep doing that and me and Adam we
didn't bumped his a million times right
but every time I'm saying hey bro you my
brother I'm looking at like a brother
right you're my brother if you wrong I'm
gonna tell you you wrong if I'm wrong
tell me I'm wrong it's a revolving door
it's not one-sided and a lot of times
like I know for me personally I know it
just felt one-sided it's like yeah you
could tell us when we wrong but when
you're wrong it's like up I ain't got to
say no it's not I'm not I'm not I'm not
I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm like bro it
don't work like that I mean I think you
know communication and common sense it
didn't play a big part in this [__] I'm
saying like communication should have
been on an all-time high you know what
I'm saying it didn't common sense just
get up in there especially if you're on
the business level and you think and put
a little sprinkle a little friendship in
there let me get in there man these
dudes is doing their thing I see him
getting hot let me go offer him some
before somebody else uh uh offering
something and let me see what that looks
like you know what I'm saying let me let
me go entertain this let me see what
this looks like and we'll be good we
didn't necessarily have to be on your
platform but it just in a perfect world
if I was to do it and I rewind it I'll
go back you know I'm saying let me sign
these guys for a year whatever keep
doing you you know I'm saying I'll take
my percentage whatever you're doing you
know I'm saying tours merch whatever the
case may be I was open to whatever you
know I'm saying I was open to whatever
anybody any deal anybody had you know
what I'm saying as soon as I began or
you know saying just leading into it
after a couple months but it's all good
man you know I'm saying it's just
business experiences that people
probably have never experienced yeah I
think that's really what it is right
it's like that's it dog it's like the
first time you go through something like
that it's like well in hindsight but at
the same time you got to kind of have
the business Acumen to be like well [__]
it's pretty obvious this is gonna this
is getting huge my Common Sense level
come on like maybe I should call a
meeting with the boys and yeah but like
when he said I don't know Joe [__] and
you like they were enthusiastic right
but I didn't know they were that
enthusiastically like that was like they
were gonna do good but I didn't know
they're gonna do that good like yeah but
you but still like you could have still
came like okay you guys are doing good
my bad let's try to see them right let's
try to see instead of me hey guys I
didn't realize this was gonna happen you
know and we would have did it yeah
instead of you still pushed this to the
side hold up all of this stuff is still
new right like we're looking at this and
like I mean you just celebrated a year
yeah you're not out of year yet are you
nah I'm at barely six months crazy
yeah it's wild cool you guys have been
killing so for the new channel obviously
your guys's
um streams on each other's on your own
respective channels are really big
um it's gonna be is it gonna be
streaming [__] or is it gonna
essentially be everything just like you
guys are getting a space we're gonna
have streaming stuff over there we're
gonna have original content any ideas
that come to mind we're gonna be signing
Talent we're gonna be doing everything
we're supposed to do yeah but we also
gonna be taking our [__] time too
we're not going to be sitting out here
rushing just throwing [__] on camera
and just doing anything you know what
I'm saying like we'll take our time with
what we got right now then we'll just
add gradually and then you'll just see
the growth and the evolution and
everything like yeah and it's no need
for us to go in here and rush but we
definitely gonna come with it you know
what I'm saying because we you know we
learn from the best and just looking
around you feel me and having that free
spirit and free mind to go out and try
to try new [__] and you know and have it
work like we've seen the ins and out of
all of that [__] and that's just that
was a great experience in itself though
so we we got the sauce you know what I'm
saying and we're just gonna implement it